welcome to this video playing booms
okanagan from from iceland and just for
change of playing the petrov it has a
really dull reputation not this one is
playing the cochrane gambit of the
petrov okay well the good thing is for
him that I don't really know what its
opening at Bishop c4 J I know that c5 is
one of the good replies what here d5
maybe d5 I can play I can take on c5
then maybe Bishop e6 yeah the thing is
in this opening you always have you have
this bad King position which is always
an issue
yeah probably all the way back so it's
it's a second of a piece against two
pawns and he's got this this big Center
trying to to get them castling behind in
b5 is going to play five maybe directly
rook f8 e 598 maybe
now that's probably not a green sari
this is probably not a way to play in
correspondence chess but in blitz er
it's certainly there is some danger
that's clear my king
okay and okay I can probably get it to
relative safety on GG ADHD Jade
everything else fails but those pawns
they are quite quite a compensation fee
5 and d5 now now I am is going to play
6m guess I came need to I need to get
the King out of out of this yeah he's
sick so what am I going to play Bishop
f6 maybe
Bishop f5 how you probably probably
replace G fire okay if he go see sex Joe
Kim Queen e7 probably
Wow that's not easy at all to play we
can probably just improve the position
slowly he does not need to rush things
like a four maybe rookie a to e1 King
age 1 prep moves I don't know if you
should do that at least I get to fire a
line open here and the pressure on c4 I
wasn't wasn't this a pretty good piece
I'm surprised that he that he did that I
came anyway
okay I'm half opened file so even rook
b4 maybe I can Bishop f5 and that's
still g4 coming I am I going to take him
now that's not so great on Oh Bishop d7
is going to play six no cannot do that
not clear at all okay let's play some
strengthening move but it's probably
helpful actually maybe I should play
Bishop b7 to threaten to take on me five
this this could be a good idea actually
I was I was reluctant to play Knight c7
because of taking a 94 but this is also
may up I should play this like 97 Bishop
d7 getting some VI okay this is at least
quickly played now yeah he's trying to
to play C for him Wow
okay but at least the night skin to get
exchanged see I'm this Bishop on c8
great maybe I can get a four in and you
can just take it I know but maybe allows
a forum and he doesn't okay hmm
yeah why does probably just completely
winning him I should have played King
edge the King edge and I must play
something to put pressure on d5 really
urgently I needed to do that Wow Joe the
bishop on c8 is just amazingly bad let's
see is there some way a key
the only hope is that he somehow screws
this up I mean it's very very good for
water yeah okay time morning it's just
amazingly bad check I'm not sure if this
was was helpful
exchanging something should check should
help me a bit
but he's got h5n8 rises even that is
just not not particularly great I have
to shop d7 now
g7 is not not easily winning at least
I'll check ok check check check
wow this was completely lost right
resigned what man if Romney wasn't it
wasn't it was still possible to screw up
it screw it up sometime somehow Wow and
what I never ever going to allow is must
prevent c4i this was this was just bad
here yeah this was just so bad i
urgently need to address this year I
need to put something on d5 so that he
cannot easily move the night and place
you for this is really this is really
important this for example I need to I
need to have Bishop t5 so that 94 is not
possible you can try to to prepare that
but I have also this move to put more
pressure on it now the other computer
gives black a win here and it's so
complicated I'm not I'm not sure that
you that you could call it the wind but
I must do that simply I must prevent c4
the position that that was arising was
just just just atrocious
look at this bishop and playing a bishop
down here the spawn only six this was
just them great this was just a gamble
maybe he allows a four I thought this
double pawn is not not useful anyway
this position I mean I'm just I'm just
in terrible shape
I think you shouldn't play this this
bishops III this exchange
I could have exchanged myself actually
here I'm just I'm just H for maybe range
4 plus 3 is the comp evaluation yeah tip
just amazingly bad disposition check
yeah this is plus 6 check so I'm h4
again which she didn't do much for
because this is the check no sorry I uh
what the heck just check I was looking
at this just went for it's not easy
actually if after this dis capture you
can take here check and this is winning
yeah it's not difficult but with the
seconds on the clock I have no way to
stop the pot this is just so bad this
Bishop great just great
ok you ain't here yeah and this is maybe
giving it away I don't know check yeah
this was a bit of a shocker but yeah
it's just not working it's just not
working he the computers is giving me
this is equal but I'm not sure this mod
I have no idea really maybe it is equal
but I rather believe that if you give it
some time it will tip to someone's favor
and I don't really see it yeah maybe it
is equal but the computer line is rookie
3 and right spot maybe I cannot really
improve here but I can go here I mean
isn't black better now yeah yeah the
computer now switches this the tips a
bit in blacks favor I will get the pawn
what a terrible position really yeah the
Cochran gambit it's not really a correct
opening but it's not so bad that you
could dismiss it outright and I simply I
simply have no knowledge what did what
you do here I mean this this was clearly
leading to a position where white has
enough flavor in a blitz game computer
actually gives white an advantage here
it's just very active ah ok thanks for
watching
tents game